council when the start of the bus smart
service started with the texting service
and we always had wanted to have a
real-time computer-based system so you
can see where the buses are and we're
now the technology is now developed to a
certain point of time where we can
actually deliver that for the customers
but it easier bus Mart service one of
the things that we've always wanted to
improve as how much time you have to
wait at a stop and the biggest
difficulty with that as always is when
is the bus coming so now with the
real-time live service on your
smartphone or iPad you can now actually
see where the buses and unique in time
it nicely to be at stop just at the
right time to catch the bus
council has been working on this
implementation of this new service for a
period of time and we've been running it
in a trial mode for the last six months
and we've starting to introduce it as a
live service since June we think it's
beneficial for users because it means
that when you you you actually can
decease how much time you need to get to
a bus stop one of the worst things that
you have is standing at a bus stop
waiting for the bus so this is the thing
that they are tells you how far the bus
is away whether it's one minute or five
minutes you can time yourself to get
there just at the right time and make
sure you catch it the bus smart services
such as for invoke are all pretty
important it's got four routes and as
part of those buses we have free Wi-Fi
on those four routes we also have access
for the people with disabilities so we
have the ability so you can them if
you're in a wheelchair you can get on
and and use the bus
we have audible announcements so it
tells you whether for the blind people
so they can actually know what they can
hear where to get off so some of those
are just features that we've
incorporated in their service to make
sure the services the best we can offer
for our customers if you would like to
know more information about trekker bus
service
feel free to ring us at the Council on
to triple one triple seven and our
customer services team will be able to
to help them with where their bus is
running or how they can actually log in
or how they can use the new information